en première réaction c'est que
maintenant je suis satisfait et entre
nous à la sélection n'a un peu beaucoup
on a beaucoup de franchise donc on avait
une très bonne entente donc sur le coup
on a discuté
ça s'est arrangé donc c'est très bien
aujourd'hui je suis champion des dom-tom
donc c'est une très bonne chose pour moi
après prédécesseurs car les enseignants
et hambourg alors on l'a dit mais quelle
stanislas était un de vos concurrents
directs comment vous avez géré cette
réalité en interne on n'a jamais eu
concrètement de rivalité entre nous on
était logique honnête il était d'abord
le lit des officiels de la sélection
donc on était à sa disposition
devant les aléas de la course ont permis
que moi je me replace en faisant mon
travail
finalement au chrono je savais que
j'allais un peu mieux que lui on s'est
motivé je pouvais pas lever le pied le
laisser gagner
on sait pas justement le rayonner emule
bas sans avoir levé le pied donc si
jamais le pied on sais pas qu'est ce que
ça aurait donné à donc aujourd'hui je
suis champion et je suis